Noel, Noel!
I got a feeling I'm not in
the Bake Off any more.
Are you a Munchkin?
No, of course not.
Where are we? How do we get
back to the tent? I don't know.
I don't have a brain.
That's the QI gig gone.
Look, there's Paul. Paul!
Hi, Noel. Hi, Munchkin.
I am not a Munchkin!
I don't have a heart.
Yeah, that's not going to come
as a big shock to people.
Raaarr!
You're bold this year.
Prue, what you doing? I was late.
It's the last costume. Come on.
ALL: # Cakes and quiches
and pies, oh, my
# Cakes and quiches
and pies, oh, my. #
Wait a second.
I can just click my heels together.
It worked!
Are you guys going to start
the show or what?
I had some kind of weird dream.
I'm not sure it was a dream.
Paul still doesn't have a heart.
Business as usual. Hmm.
NOEL AND SANDI: Welcome to
The Great British Bake Off.
So, are you going to wear
that for the whole season?
I thought I might, yeah.
Yeah, it's a strong look.
I don't think this show
can have too much gingham.
Is it weird that I fancy you now?
So do I.
The winner of
The Great British Bake Off is...
APPLAUSE
It's our tenth anniversary, but who
will be our tenth Bake Off champion?
The first time I saw the tent,
I just thought, "What!?"
Just the most surreal thing ever.
It's just insane.
Very nervous. I've watched
the Bake Off every season
and to actually be here,
I can't quite believe it.
Absolutely terrified.
I baked along with Bake Off
last year and now it's there.
It doesn't seem real yet.
Not until Sandi or Noel says...
On your marks. Get set. "Bake."
This year, the Bake Off has
gone one better... Really?
..with 13 home bakers from across
the country.
Oh, my days.
Tenth year. We're bringing back
the baker's dozen.
It could be any point
in the next nine weeks
that two people could leave.
I feel like I've got a sweat on.
Last year, the bar really went up.
This year I want to be
inspired by those 13 bakers
and I'm longing to taste
what they bake.
This year's challenges have been
carefully devised to conjure up some
of the most spectacular home baking
the competition has ever seen.
I think everyone's feeling a bit
worried about being the worst.
I keep forgetting that the
technical's a thing, obviously,
cos I can't practise it.
Then I'm like, "Oh, my God,
the technical, it's something
else to think about."
I think baking and being a vet do
complement each other.
We use quite a lot of needles and
syringes, catheters, bits and bobs.
Some more normal than others.
Will Paul and Prue be impressed
with our baker's dozen?
Meeting Paul and Prue is going
to be nerve-racking.
My belly's in knots.
I've been up in the middle of the
night saying, "I can't do this."
I just don't want to be
shaking the whole time.
I once made a wedding
cake for someone,
but I didn't even stick around to
hear how it went or if it fell.
I wouldn't say I'm a high achiever.
I'd say I achieve certain
things in sort of the same way
that you can achieve a hangover.
SANDI: On our tenth anniversary...
Hopefully it'll stay.
It hasn't fallen over yet.
..in our biggest competition ever...
Mayhem is the best word for it.
..who will be crowned the winner...
He's doing the Bake Off thing!
Does it work? No.
THEY LAUGH
..of The Great British Bake Off?
Oh, the shakes, oh, the shakes.
Let's not drop the cake.
It's faultless, actually.
I'm dribbling.
Prue, you've got to stop saying
that.
THEY LAUGH
Once again, we've pitched our tent
at Welford Park in Berkshire,
the home of the Bake Off.
We start with Cake Week
and over the next two days,
our new batch of bakers will
face three challenges,
after which, one of them will be
crowned our first Star Baker
and another will have
to leave the tent.
Morning, bakers.
Welcome to your very first
day in the tent.
How marvellous to see you all
looking quite so relaxed.
Now, here is the important thing,
there are 13 of you, what people
used to call a baker's dozen.
Well, mainly old people.
Old people. I think, yeah.
What it means is that at any point,
two of you might be
leaving the tent.
Could be this week. Could be the
semifinal. We just don't know.
Now, for your first-ever
Signature Challenge,
the judges would like you
to bake a fruitcake.
It can be any size, any shape...
But it must contain a significant
amount of dried fruit.
Significant. Yeah, more than
one currant, I think.
Five? Yeah, five is fine.
Five is significant. Yeah.
Now, as well as being
perfectly baked,
it must be beautifully decorated.
You have two and a half hours.
On your marks. Get set. Bake.
Finally doing it, can you
believe it? It's madness.
God! I'm freaking out.
I am nervous.
I'm trying to find my
measuring thing now.
My God, I'm in a tizz already.
The fruitcake for me is
one of those basics of baking.
Pick a great sponge base,
fill it with fruit,
but it's about the consistency
of the batter.
Too thin, all the fruit will
drop down to the bottom.
Too thick, they all stay at the top.
Get the balance right
and it will bake beautifully.
They've only got
two and a half hours
so they have to get those cakes into
the oven, out of the oven
and get it cooled, because we
want it decorated as well,
and there's a real danger that
they'll be putting icing onto
a hot cake and it'll just melt.
Just trying not to cut myself.
It's really sharp.
Ah, I need a plaster from somebody.
At this stage, I think the
bakers will be quite nervous,
but I think every year of Bake Off
the standard's got better
and better and better
and I expect this year
to be exactly the same.
Hello. Good morning. How are you?
Good morning, love.
Right, tell us all about your
fruitcake. What are you doing?
So I'm doing, like,
a Christmas cake,
it's something my mum used to make
all the time when I was a kid.
She'd literally make them
in October, like,
soak the fruit beforehand and then
keep pouring brandy in them.
So, to speed things up a bit,
I've put my fruit over heat
and just let it simmer while
I'm getting the cake mix ready.
I do it like you do it. Oh, do you?
I never bother to do it ahead. Yeah.
Amelia is a fashion designer
from Halifax
and she's been baking with her mum
Julia since she was five.
Lots of washing up for Mum?
Yeah. Great.
Her mum's recipe demands
over 700g of mixed fruit,
all infused with orange brandy.
That is definitely a significant
amount of fruit.
Yeah, definitely at least
four currants.
And, obviously, putting
that much fruit in it,
how long are you baking it for?
It's quite a low temperature
for about an hour and 15 minutes.
Fingers crossed. Do you think
that will be a bit...? Yeah.
It'll be close, but I think
it'll be fine.
Have you finished with the brandy
now? Not yet. Oh.
But I'll let you know when I have.
Thanks, darling. Good luck.
Thank you.
Amelia isn't the only one
following in the family footsteps.
This is my grandma's recipe
I'm using.
I think she's pleased
I'm using it. I don't know.
I don't think she's angry.
HE LAUGHS
Five other bakers are ALSO using
recipes that have been
passed down through generations.
I'm making Bara Brith Teulu Ni,
which is my family's Bara Brith,
and I brought my own eggs from the
chickens that they laid this week.
I'm hoping, secret weapon. They're
just super rich and super tasty.
SANDI: Michelle grew up on
her parent's smallholding
in Caernarfon, Wales.
She now lives in Tenby
with husband Ben,
son Alfie and their three chickens,
Chip, Hawker and Blossom.
This is worse than trying
to herd the sheep. Come on.
As well as their eggs,
she'll use strong tea to soak
the fruit for her family's
Bara Brith, giving it an extra kick,
along with an icing made with
her husband's favourite Welsh rum.
Oh, my God, my husband actually
thinks I look like you.
Wow. We should play a trick on him.
Do you think? No?
Don't we look alike?
Let's play a trick on him.
What, you go home? Next time you're
about to go on holiday.
I'll turn up at the airport, go on
holiday with him for three weeks,
see if he notices. OK. Yeah, fine.
A pleasure talking to you, and say
hello to your husband. I will.
Well, I'll say hello to him when
we go on holiday together. OK.
I love a bit of zest.
I am making my Great Grandma Rosie's
fruitcake.
I think it does help to have
the family connection there.
You feel like they're with you,
holding your hand.
Steph's love of baking was inspired
by her great-grandma, Rosie.
Steph is from Chester and works
at her mum's classic car business.
Can I have one of these?
She's attempting a vintage look for
her citrus and apricot fruitcake
with candied oranges and
marzipan roses
in honour of her
great-grandma, Rosie.
Is your great-grandma still around?
She's not, no. Aw.
But she will find anything.
If you lose anything, just get
in touch. Really? She's on it.
I've lost a pair of socks, I'm going
to come chat with you. Excellent.
I've lost my mind, actually.
Um... Um, not sure.
I think that's beyond Grandma.
When it comes to channelling
Grandma...
That's the mango.
..Steph won't be alone.
I'm making an updated version
of my grandma's, sort of,
basic normal tea loaf recipe.
So I'm adding my own dried fruit.
But what I didn't realise
is when you dry it,
just how little it actually weighs,
and so I've just had to dry more and
more and more and more of the fruit.
I had to finish it off at work,
so I think they think I'm an
awfully crazy person now, but...
Rosie's a vet in Somerset
and when she isn't drying
fruit at work,
she proves dough in the warmth
of her pet python Minnie's vivarium.
Perfect temperature.
As well as adding her own dried
apples, strawberry and mango,
she's also updating Grandma's
recipe with Indian chai.
I'm just trying to get as much of
the chai flavour as I possibly can.
Rather than trying to
make it look super fancy,
I'm going for tasting good, so if
that goes wrong, I'm screwed.
One, two, three, four.
As Rosie heads east,
she'll have company.
When I go over to India, on all
the trains they come through,
like, offering you chai and it's,
like, the tastiest thing.
Raised in Perthshire, Michael's mum
Nicola and his dad Sam
have ensured his Scottish and
Indian heritage were celebrated
in his baking as soon as he could
reach the kitchen counter.
You used to be on your
climb up. Hmm.
He's aiming high with chai spices,
chopped sultanas and apricots
and a piped henna-style decoration
that will require a steady hand.
Mum texted me at five
this morning saying,
"Be calm, be slow, be confident."
It's going to be fine.
I just... Ow, my God.
I've done it again.
I'm so sorry. Michael, again?
For goodness' sake,
this is so stupid.
It's the beginning, everybody
gets really stressed.
Less haste, more speed. Yes. OK.
This has to be the last one.
I don't have many left.
But the greatest danger in this
first fruitcake challenge...
Oh, my God.
It's, like, pressure's on.
..is the fruit itself.
Bit more fruit in.
Too much will overwhelm
their batter...
I'm getting a bit
OCD about my numbers.
..resulting in a stodgy,
underbaked cake.
That looks a lot thicker
than when I did it at home.
But Dan has made a last-minute
change to his recipe.
I've, like, doubled my amount
of fruit in it today.
Yeah, significant.
Yeah, you said significant,
I thought, "Oh!"
So, literally today
you've changed it?
I've changed it, yeah.
My concern is whether
you're going to have time
to bake this now much bigger cake.
Can I just warn you? This is not
a good face, this face here.
Yeah, I can tell.
Dan lives and works in Rotherham
and is a support worker for people
with learning difficulties.
That's it - a good, big blob, Dave.
He'll add spiced rum buttercream
and coffee and almond brittle
to decorate his, now much larger,
rum-soaked fruitcake.
I feel like you've got no room
here to operate. I know.
I know. I feel like you just want
to throw all this on the floor.
Watch this. There you go.
Watch this. Watch this.
There you go. Fly, my pretty.
Do you know what? That works. Fly.
Look at this. Take your
shoes off, get comfy...
..nail this! Thank you, sir.
Whilst Dan's recipe is expanding...
Da-da-da-be-da.
..David's recipe is missing
something.
My fruitcake has no fat.
That's unusual.
I love healthy baking.
David is from Yorkshire and when
he's not travelling the world
working as an international
health advisor,
he's fanatical about keeping fit.
Oof!
HE LAUGHS
As well as replacing fat
with carrot and squash,
David has found another healthy
alternative for his fruit.
I'm using dried prunes and figs.
It does sound like a cake
that's going to keep you regular if
I may say so. Oh, yeah absolutely.
Yeah. Well, yeah, I need that. Good
luck. Too much information, David.
Thank you very much indeed.
Thank you very much, thanks.
Bakers, you are halfway through
your first Signature Challenge.
Wow, first time call of the season.
Was I good? No.
Now it's the point of no return.
I've used this tin before where
half of the cake stayed in the tin
and we don't want that to
happen today.
That's fruitcake, innit? I don't
know what Paul's worried about.
Yeah, I'll show him.
HE LAUGHS
The more fruit they've added
in order to impress the judges...
Come on, please come out good.
..the longer their cakes will
need in the oven.
Just hope for the best.
Low and slow. I'm going to
check it after an hour.
160 for about 40 minutes.
In.
Oh, that felt good.
So we're going to set
a timer for 50.
Start.
She's in. She's in.
Come on!
But one baker isn't quite
ready to hit the oven.
I've just made the marzipan.
Going to make a ring
around the middle of the cake.
HORN BEEPS
Phil is a lorry driver from Essex,
where he lives with his wife Angela
and two daughters, 16-year-old
Lexie and 11-year-old Pippa.
Oh, you want a bit? Tough. Oh!
Ha-ha!
As well as marzipan, he's adding
cinnamon, ginger, nutmeg,
allspice and cloves to a fruitcake
that's become a family project.
My wife and I have got a really
good baking relationship
and she's come up with
this, sort of, idea,
so I just do what she says
like any normal married man.
This year's first
Signature Challenge...
So here we go. Be kind.
..is about to get even trickier.
Check the cakes.
Whilst constantly checking their
fruitcakes' progress in the oven...
It's not burnt yet.
..the bakers will now need to use
every minute to create
beautiful decorations
the judges have demanded.
And Priya is hoping to impress
by bringing the inside of
her cake to the outside.
This will look better, I promise.
Priya's an aspiring
novelist from Leicester
and mum to two-year-old Kian
and four-year-old Liam.
Oh, that's good!
Her cake will be filled with
dried tropical fruit
and to decorate she's handcrafting
oranges and bananas in marzipan.
What else are you going to make?
It's going to be a pineapple.
Pineapple? Eventually. It's like
a psychedelic snowman...
It is at the moment, yeah, it looks
a bit crazy. ..with a hat.
Look at that.
Alice is also going for a stand-out
look with her fruit decoration.
So, making a gingerbread fruit
wreath and then I'm just going to
cover the whole thing in gold.
It's going to be a bit glitzy.
Alice works at a school in central
London as a geography teacher
and uses her baking to help her
pupils with their coursework.
So, using your spoons, you are going
to be the waves, the erosion.
Snow white royal icing will coat
her Christmassy fruit and
gingerbread wreath,
which she's hoping will
pack a gingery punch.
And I've added some extra
crystallised ginger
cos I absolutely love ginger,
so I'm just chucking that
all over the place, really.
Whilst Alice looks forward
to Christmas...
I'm doing, like, a Simnel cake.
..Jamie is already
celebrating Easter.
It's going to have,
like, chicks on it,
instead of just balls of marzipan.
That one's called Barney.
HE LAUGHS
Jamie is currently on a gap year
and lives in Dorking with
his identical twin brother Alex,
their mum Charlotte and their
baking mentor, dad Pat.
Is that the cake
I taught you to make?
No, it isn't.
Jamie's adapted his nan's
traditional recipe to create
a double-layered Simnel cake.
So you get two layers of marzipan
and... Yeah, exactly.
..marzipan on the top. Yeah.
Good, I like a lot of marzipan.
How old are you, Jamie? I'm 20.
Does your mum know you're here?
She does. I'm allowed out.
NOEL: When it comes to
her decoration,
Helena is getting into a different
kind of holiday spirit.
I live like every day is Halloween
so I'm doing bat wings
made out of sugar.
Try to spookify a fruitcake.
Halloween-obsessed Helena grew up
in Lanzarote and now lives in Leeds
with her rescue dog Cato, husband
Will and baby daughter Flora.
SHE GURGLES
Oh, Flora will love it.
Her caramel bat wings will decorate
her spooky spiced pumpkin and maple
fruitcake,
flavoured with dried prunes
and toasted pecans.
They're not right.
It's crystallised, the caramel.
What a disaster.
I've never had a problem
with caramel.
You've got time.
From one Goth to another,
I know you're going to be fine.
I'll be in my coffin if you want me.
I'm just going to start it again.
# I got time
# I got love... #
Henry will only have time for
one attempt at his decoration.
This is a royal icing little house
to go on the top of the cake.
It's just a bit time-consuming.
Oh, my God, stop shaking.
Henry is studying English Literature
at Durham University
and in between his studies, he loves
to sing at his local church.
# Shall all your cares beguile. #
He's hoping to hit all
the right notes with his take on
a Wood Street cake, an almost
400-year-old recipe
which he'll bring to life with
his royal icing house
and piped chocolate trees.
Cos a Wood Street cake
looks quite plain,
so I just wanted
to embellish it a bit.
I've got to build this,
that's another thing.
It looks quite nice, laid out.
I think you've done an amazing
job to get it this far.
Look forward to it. Yep.
Thank you very much.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
No-one looked up. No, nobody.
Everyone just went, "We've got
watches, what's the point of this?"
TIMER BLEEPS
That's yours, Michelle.
I'm just going to have a look.
There's more to baking fruitcake
than meets the eye.
It does look done, but now
I'm like, "Is it done?"
With so much fruit inside, if
they're not cooked for long enough,
the centre could still be raw.
It's brown on top, I mean,
I don't know what it's going
to be like in the middle.
But achieving the perfect bake...
Ugh!
..isn't their only concern.
Is yours out the oven yet?
No, not yet.
Cos I don't want
to leave it too long.
Breathe, you'll be fine.
The bakers need to leave enough
time for the cakes to cool
before they can start to decorate.
At home, I iced it
when it was still warm
and it just waterfalled down the
side, which is not where I want it.
I'm going to go in.
I can't wait any more.
I'm going to stick a skewer in
to see if it's cooked.
And that should come out
pretty much clean,
but if it hits the fruit,
you can get a bit of, sort of,
gunky stuff on it.
That's really not clean, is it?
No, it's not ready.
Not done, not done, not done.
Fail, fail, fail.
Not done.
Oh, it's cooked,
it's actually cooked.
Spot on. Oh, yeah!
This is going in the fridge.
Immediately.
That's not done.
I perhaps should've been
a lot more prepared.
Bakers, just 15 minutes. Urgh!
I feel like I've got a sweat on.
It's happened again.
It's not caramelising, so I thought
I'd just pour the sugar
and see if it sets.
If it doesn't work,
I'm going to be really gutted.
Oh, the shakes, oh, the shakes.
Look at that, that's an
intricate job. Thank you.
But I just need to get
this on top of the cake now.
How you going to do it? Um... Just
like... up and just pick it up.
Right, is it ready?
It's going to have to come out.
I'm not happy.
Pretty certain it's not
going to cool in time.
I'm going to pop it in the freezer
and I'm going to stab it
with some really cold skewers.
It's probably a really bad plan.
We just do strange things to cakes
sometimes. Mine's boiling hot.
So as long as it comes out of
the tin and then it doesn't
break in half, I'll be fine.
This is the tricky bit.
Let's go for it
and see what happens.
Moment of truth.
Oh, yes.
Happy with that.
I'll put them back in the fridge.
Oh, that looks OK!
Why is it not working? Come on.
Oh!
Bit of it got stuck. Argh!
Bakers, you've got
five minutes left. Really?
Ooh! My cake's too hot.
My cake's too hot.
I think that bit goes there.
I didn't expect to be doing this
with basically one hand.
This is just like liquidised sugar.
Got to do something.
Then just let the rum icing
run down the side.
It's beautiful! Thank you, darling.
I'm just trying to cool it down
quickly. It's just so hot.
He's doing the Bake Off thing!
Does it work? No.
THEY LAUGH
It's already melting.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Cake's still too hot, so it's
pulling the cake apart.
No, no, it's bending.
Dammit. They've gone, "Vmmm."
I'm popping this on.
Give me one sec,
cos my hands are shaking.
Oh, God, I can feel my heart
pounding out of my chest.
Do you want a hand? If you can
make the brittle, brittle.
Oh, balls.
The worst has happened.
HE LAUGHS
Oh, my God. The actual worst.
Bakers, your time is up.
That's it, end of your
first challenge.
Oh.
Please place your cakes
at the end of your benches.
First one, bagged.
You've nailed that.
Not good.
What a mess.
Urgh.
The word "infuriating"
does not sum up that feeling.
SANDI: The bakers will now face
the judgment of Paul and Prue
for the very first time.
Hello, Priya. Hello. Hi, Priya.
For subtitling services, contatct:
waqas.zahoor89@gmail.com
I love the decoration,
it's simplistic but effective.
NOEL: I'm getting Wham video.
Yeah, Club Tropicana. Yeah.
Let's have a look inside.
Wow. Looks like a good piece
of cake. Lovely colour.
I think you've got
what you asked for. Oh.
It's light, very summery.
The tropical fruits in it give it
that gorgeous citrus flavour.
I think it's a well-baked...
Original. ..different cake.
Thank you. Thank you. Excellent.
WHISPERS: Nailed it!
It's got a very Easter feel,
hasn't it?
Have you made eye-less chicks?
He didn't want them to see
the horror of your judging.
It holds together beautifully.
That is delicious.
It is mostly marzipan, which I love.
The fruit content
in there is perfect.
That's a great bake.
It's a great flavour.
Well done. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Absolutely destroyed that.
There was a hut but it's now
a little bit of a wreck.
My hands were a bit shaky.
I saw it. It looked amazing.
It looked beautiful.
More important is the bake.
Henry, you have made
a very good cake.
Oh, thank God.
I think the texture's beautiful,
it's well-baked.
I think it's a great cake.
Yay! Thank you.
Lovely definition, great colour.
I like the stars as well.
Did that bit stick a bit?
A little bit, yeah.
Well, you can't say
there's no fruit in there.
It's very moist, but I think
the flavour is absolutely lovely.
It screams Christmas.
That's a great tea loaf.
Well done.
Ah!
Do you know? I think it looks
absolutely beautiful.
I like the way
you've iced between the ridges
which you've got
out of the tin perfectly.
Oh, my goodness.
Marzipan right down the middle.
Perfect.
Quite spicy.
And that's all you get.
You don't really get the fruit.
Just think the flavours
are slightly out of balance.
OK. Thank you. Thank you.
So close.
I had trouble with the decoration.
Just could not work it out.
If it's not right, don't
put them on. Lesson learned, yeah.
It's very spicy.
It's almost savoury.
I quite like it, actually.
I've never had
anything like it before.
When you put the icing on,
was the cake still warm, I take it?
Yes, it was. Which is why
the drip hasn't really worked.
But, I think it looks attractive,
good colour.
Oof. That's not the noise
you want to hear, is it? No.
"Urgh!"
Texture is a little bit tough for me
but I think the flavour is
fantastic.
OK, thank you.
I think it's a great looking cake,
actually, great colour.
Very nice. It's a juicy cake.
It's delicious.
Isn't it? The apricot
comes through beautifully.
I just want to pick up that slice
and walk out of here. Go for it.
I can't. I've got a few more
people to judge. I was going to say
you've got a few more left.
The cake looks a little bit sad.
It does. A bit flat.
Shall we have a taste of it?
I'm hoping it'll be lovely anyway.
Cinnamon. Hmm. You've gone
a little bit overboard with that.
It's very chewy, that hints
at being underbaked. Hmm.
Back to the drawing board.
It's a lovely looking loaf.
Very good marzipan. Maybe slightly
too much almond essence.
The moistness, great.
The texture is perfect.
I think if you'd pulled back
on the almond essence,
you would've had a perfect loaf.
You'd hang that on a door,
wouldn't you?
Well, it is a wreath.
Christmas time. Christmas wreath.
I love ginger.
Yeah, it's got a kick to it.
It has. The crystallised ginger
is beautiful.
You could've pulled back
a little bit on the other ginger.
Nice idea. Sometimes,
going back to basics... Yeah.
..don't try and overdo something.
Yeah.
The decoration is beautifully done
in spite of having your fingers up.
It's like a pincer.
I think the flavour is
absolutely lovely. Oh.
I think you've created
a very good tea cake.
Well done. Thank you.
Not bad considering
you've only got one finger.
You look a bit nervous.
Yeah, can't see why.
Well, it certainly does
look a bit rustic.
You added more fruit
to this, didn't you?
Yeah. I'm going to check
to see whether you managed
to bake that all the way through.
I'm not sure. That's a big slice.
I'm afraid he was right.
Oh, my God. That's raw.
The alcohol you've got in there
actually tastes quite nice.
I think your flavours are good,
I just think your baking's way out.
I knew that. Thanks for confirming.
That went well.
I think he said
the flavour of the booze was good.
That's all I heard.
It went really well!
I'm absolutely buzzing.
I really hope my great-grandma Rosie
was looking down on me.
I think she was there.
Kind of a bit shocked.
That was all right.
Next one, try not to
cut off any more limbs.
I'm really chuffed.
I feel like I'm in a good place
going to the technical.
What's the worst that could happen?
NOEL: The bakers were able to
practise their fruitcakes,
but their next challenge is their
first gingham-shrouded mystery.
SANDI: Hello, bakers, and welcome to
your very first technical challenge,
which today has been set for you
by Prudence. Any advice?
The secret of success is accuracy.
Yeah, I have that on a tapestry.
NOEL: As ever, your Technical
Challenge will be judged blind.
So, we're going to have to ask
Prudence and Paulette
to leave the tent. Yeah, off you go.
Do you know what they're up to?
Paul's bought two leotards
and a pommel horse.
Ah, PE lesson.
Right,
so for your Technical Challenge,
Prue would like you to make
six identical angel cake slices.
Each made of three
layers of Genoise sponge.
Now, the sponge layers must be
sandwiched with a silky
smooth Italian meringue buttercream.
Your angel cake slices should be
topped with icing and feathered.
Whatever that may be.
Feathers on cakes. You've got
an hour and three quarters.
On your marks. Get set. Bake.
Oh, God. I didn't want a Genoise
sponge and what have we got?
Genoise sponge.
I love an angel cake
but I like the cheap one,
like, the 50p job.
But, like, this is a proper one.
SANDI: To make the angel cakes, the
bakers have all been given the same
ingredients and Prue's
complex 15-stage recipe.
This is a bit,
as they say, technical.
It's so complicated.
There's a lot of room
for error here, huge error.
Great choice, Prue.
Angel cake slices
for the first technical
these bakers will have to face.
I am feeling a little mean.
It sounds simple enough but
the point is it's a Genoise sponge
and it's really easy for
that mixture to become flat.
If they over-mix, it's not
just volume they'll lose -
the texture becomes rubbery
and it has to be light.
Now let's have a taste.
Takes me back, actually,
to when I was a kid.
You get the raspberry,
you get the lemon.
I've just got a vanilla one.
The flavours are delicate
but strong enough.
I think they taste delicious.
I think it's a great challenge.
We don't know what
the bakers are like.
We're beginning to get to know them
and I think that's
a pretty cruel Technical Challenge.
Great, though. Great, though.
You like a bit of cruelty.
I do, yeah.
That starts them off
on the right foot.
First, fold the foil paper
to divide the cake tin
into three even sections.
Got some maths in here.
So, it could go brilliantly,
or it could go horribly.
It's a little bit of origami
at the moment.
Because of
my signature this morning,
I've definitely got
a lot more pressure.
But, luckily, the instructions
so far look pretty clear.
So far. I'm only on step one.
Right, so for the Genoise,
tip the eggs and sugar into a bowl,
whisk the mixture
until it reaches 43 degrees.
I've never made a Genoise, dammit!
NOEL: If the bakers don't
whisk for long enough...
This is where
I get a good strong arm.
..they won't get enough air
into the Genoise sponge to create
the volume that Prue is expecting.
When I've made Genoise in the past,
it just ends up like a...
..hard like a slipper. Oh.
OK, how many angel cake slices
have you made in your lifetime?
Uh, none. None. No, none, none,
none. That's because you're 12.
Do I look that young?
That's why I get ID'd.
Is that what it is?
Everywhere I go. Do you? Yeah.
I got ID'd in Arizona.
It was very dark.
Just saying.
It was really, really dark.
43 degrees. We are done. Come off.
Whoo. Whisk the mixture
into ribbon stage. Fine, OK.
We're going to go fast.
It only takes a while.
When you lift up the whisk
and you draw it over the batter,
it leaves, like, a ribbon effect.
I kind of think that's ribbon stage.
This, I think, is perfect.
Meanwhile, divide the flour
and the butter evenly between
three small bowls, one, two, three.
I've literally got
a thousand bowls on my place.
SANDI: Prue is expecting
three layers of Genoise sponge...
So, we've got lemon,
raspberry and vanilla.
..each with a different colour
and flavour.
NOEL: It's like that thing where
you go, "WHOO, whoo, whoo..."
Have you made these before?
Tried Genoise once and botched it.
Don't say that on the camera.
Too late.
Good luck. Thank you. Whoo.
It doesn't tell us how much of the
vanilla or raspberry or anything.
So, you're just going to have to
judge how strong
you think the flavour should be.
We don't want it to be lacking.
Teaspoon.
Cup and a half?
Going to go half.
Ah, go on, two.
OK, so, raspberry flavouring
and pink food gel.
I don't know how much of that.
I'm thinking quite a pale pink.
Looks good enough to me.
I'm not going to put
all of the lemon zest in.
It's a big lemon
so that's still quite a bit.
Oh, that is a lot of yellow.
Orange, yellow. It's a spectrum.
Working with one bowl at a time,
sieve the flour over the egg,
add the butter and fold it through.
So, you fold it really gently cos
you've whisked all the air into it.
You don't want to knock it out.
Just trying not to over-mix it
but just want to get the colour
to spread throughout.
Gently, gently.
Don't upset the judges.
I don't know if I've over...
over-whisked it or not
but it's gone flat, basically.
What's wrong? It's just got,
it's got no air in it.
This is going to be
as flat as a pancake.
I need to start again.
I don't know
how to make this app work.
Oh, it's cos it's
a Technical Challenge.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
So, pour the three batters
into the sections of the tins
and then bake it.
If you look at the yellow one, it's
half the volume of the pink one.
But I don't have time
to do it again.
I'm just redoing my sponges.
I don't know why
this is confusing me so much.
I'm going in.
How long for?
No, there's no telling us.
Seven minutes, eight minutes.
Something like that and check it.
I don't know.
I'll just keep my eye on it.
I'm a bit worried cos it's so thin,
it is so easy to over-bake it.
I'm nervous, I'm nervous.
SANDI: And in time-call news...
Bakers, you've got
half an hour left. What?
That's all from us.
Oh, that's no good, is it?
I'm going to run out of time.
I need to make the Italian meringue.
I actually know how to make that.
Slowly pour the hot syrup
onto the egg white.
Then she says, "Add the
butter until the buttercream
is smooth and thick."
Should go nice and glossy.
Looks OK at the moment.
I've come to love you, Jamie,
cos I think you might need it.
Yeah, it's failed again, so...
What went wrong?
It turned out like this. OK.
And then I tried to make it again.
A bit lumpy.
And then it got even worse
so now I'm actually...
It is a bit lumpy, darling.
It's, it's rubbish.
It's not even worth putting that in.
I'm only doing two layers.
These have been in for 12 minutes.
Yeah, I'm getting it out.
I don't know if
this is meant to look like this.
I said I putting them
in the oven for ten minutes.
It still says ten minutes.
I never started the timer.
Oh. They look a bit like an Aero.
They're about twice
the height of mine.
Seriously, my sponge is like rubber.
It looks all right, actually.
So, sandwich with buttercream.
This is not buttercream.
This is meringue. So bad.
I've not had any angel cakes before.
Hopefully, this is right.
It's not looking quite right.
But I'm making the buttercream.
I'm going to do nothing.
Cover with the white fondant icing
and feather with the pink.
I'm not sure whether to ice it
and then cut it,
or to cut it and then ice it.
I'm going for ice then slice.
It says to do that.
I'm being very obedient.
Five minutes left.
We've got five minutes?
Don't panic! Don't panic!
Look at that. They might actually
refuse to try it.
I literally wouldn't be surprised.
It is rubber.
I'm not even just saying that.
So, I've got to draw some lines.
I've never feathered before.
The secret to feathering
is a sharp cocktail stick
and wet icing.
Mine has gone mental.
What the hell did I get myself into?
My hands are shaking a bit.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
No! Oh, my days.
My hands are shaking so much.
It's going to get chucked
in the bin.
Like, literally that's inedible.
If it fell on the floor,
it'll bounce right back.
I can say with confidence
I won't be winning this challenge.
Cut it into six, right?
Enough for everyone.
NOEL: Bakers, that is the end
of your Technical Challenge.
Oh, well.
Well done, everybody.
Please bring your bakes
up to the table and place them
in front of your photograph.
They're not going to eat it.
It's inedible, like, literally.
Dan, do you want to swap?
Prue and Paul will now judge the
bakers' first Technical Challenge.
They're expecting six identical
angel cake slices,
filled with silky
Italian meringue buttercream,
and topped with
a feathered fondant icing.
OK...
It's lost all the height,
and the spring in the sponge.
And that red is too much.
Where's the silky smooth Italian
buttercream? That's melted.
It's not there. It's melted out.
Flavours are there,
but it's like rubber.
If I dropped that on the floor, it'd
bounce up and hit me in the face.
This one's feathering's better.
However, still not as high
as they should be.
Your flavours are there.
They had too much icing
on the top, I think.
Moving on, these look all the same.
I mean, that is much higher,
isn't it?
And it's pink, rather than red.
It's got nice flavours in there.
Yeah, that's not bad.
I think this is another -
not to mince words - failure.
Where's the bottom layer?
It's missing one.
CONTESTANTS LAUGH
Do you know,
it actually tastes rather nice?
We're missing a layer,
and rubbery to taste as well.
This looks a little
bit more delicate.
There's a bit of height
to that sponge. And everything
is pastel shades.
Mmm. This tastes delicious.
Yeah, and the raspberry one's OK.
Right. I like
the feathering on this.
Yeah. They are fairly equal.
Buttercream's good. Nice flavour.
OK, moving on again. It's very thin.
It's lost all its height.
But the buttercream looks beautiful.
They're not bad. Hmm, a bit rubbery.
This looks quite delicate. However,
the two sponges look the same.
And the lemon should have
a little bit of colour.
Hmm, it's a bit tough. Hmm, it is.
Now, I like the feathering
on that one. It's very neat.
And that looks jolly tough.
It's just dried a bit on the edges,
but it's not that tough.
Talk about neat - that's not.
The sponge is OK, but
they're still not high enough.
The flavours are OK.
Moving on, it's the highest one.
The highest, which is really good.
And soft.
I mean, it's hideous
fondant on the top.
It's a very good cake there.
Then you move on to this.
Lots of buttercream,
not bad feathering.
Flavours are all right. It's
certainly got the height, that one.
Last but maybe least,
we've got very thin layers again.
It's nice, shiny fondant.
Quite tough. Very tough.
SANDI: Prue and Paul will now rank
the cakes, from worst to best.
This - number 13.
Who's responsible for it?
Jamie, it was pretty awful.
Thank you.
Twelfth spot is... this one.
That was me.
Not surprised, blood red in
the middle, and a bit rubbery.
Number 11 is this one.
Michael. Sorry.
It tasted nice, but
they were pretty uneven.
NOEL: David is tenth. Ninth, Dan.
Eighth, Phil. Seventh, Priya.
Sixth, Michelle. Alice is fifth.
And Amelia is fourth.
Now, number three was this one.
Stephanie.
I mean, your icing was terrible...
Thank you.
..but the flavour matters
more than anything.
And number two...
..is this one.
Um, not bad at all.
Nice bit of feathering, nice and
equal, and the buttercream was good.
Which means that
this one is number one.
Henry, well done!
Very good feathering, and excellent
in every way, really, so well done.
Thank you very much. Thank you.
To win at the first Technical, that
feels just quite... quite pleasing.
Second, awesome. Chuffed with that.
After this morning, I needed that.
I sort of feel that
I've clawed my way back,
and I'm not bottom-bottom any more.
The Technical was supposed to be
the one that saved me.
It didn't quite, so it's all
on the Showstopper tomorrow.
If that doesn't go well,
I'm a goner.
I knew, midway through,
that I was going to come last,
but I just wanted to get
something fairly...
well, it wasn't even respectable,
was it? - something on the plate.
SANDI: Just one challenge remains,
before the first Star
Baker is crowned,
and one baker will have to
leave the tent.
Hello, bakers.
It's time for your first ever
Showstopper.
So, today Paul and Prue would
like you to make a birthday cake,
but not just any old birthday cake.
They want the birthday cake
you dreamt of as a child.
The cake that I dreamt of as a child
had marzipan arms,
and we just held hands together.
That's nice. Yeah.
Weirdo. OK, the flavours, fillings,
and decorations are
entirely up to you,
but please remember
it is a Showstopper,
it needs to be
spectacular and sizeable.
You've got four hours.
On your marks. Get set. Bake.
Ooh. Every minute, there's, like,
100% always something to do.
It's going to be full-on,
a crazy four hours.
Mayhem is the best word for it.
We will see.
Time will be their enemy.
It's all about colour,
it's about detail, it's about wow.
They've got to show us
what they can do.
That's going in t'oven.
You're kidding me?
Oh, wow, you're joking.
It's not funny.
I'm rather hoping
for some originality.
Children dream a lot.
I want them to try to remember
what they dreamt about.
But, as always, what matters
far more than anything
is the quality of the cake.
The flavours
should be real and punchy.
It has to be delicious.
I think it gives us a chance to
dig around in the bakers' skills,
and find out a little bit
about our baker's dozen.
Good morning. Hi. Hello, Helena.
So, it's obviously chocolate cake.
Tell us what you're going to make
with the cake?
It's, er, a fairy garden.
I had a fairy garden as a child.
I have one now.
You've got a what, sorry?
A fairy garden, now.
You've got a furry garden?
Fairy g... is it my accent?
Oh, a fairy garden.
What did you think she said?
Well, like fur? Furry garden?
No, fairy garden!
Oh, Paul,
I know what you're thinking.
SANDI: Helena's perfectly-manicured
"fairy garden" will be covered
in green desiccated coconut grass
and chocolate tree bark.
So how big is your,
erm, fairy garden?
NOEL LAUGHS
You're going to put these two,
and then these two...?
Correct, yeah.
So it's a fairy mountain.
Yeah, yeah. It...
Oh, God, I can't do it.
SANDI: Helena's not
the only baker...
Better not put my hands in there.
..away with the fairies.
I am making a ty tylwyth teg,
which means "fairy cake" in Welsh.
Featuring a toadstool house,
built out of carrot cake,
Michelle's inspiration also
comes from childhood fantasies
of fairies living at
the bottom of the garden.
My sister and I, we always
found that really magical.
It's something that
reminded me of my childhood,
so it's something
I want to do today.
Steph's Showstopper is based
on a childhood memory
she'd rather forget.
It is a really sweet picture.
I loved ice cream. But I'm
a little bit accident-prone, so...
You dropped it?
..splat. Yeah.
NOEL: Carved out of coconut
and raspberry ripple cake,
Steph's hoping
her giant upside-down ice cream
won't slip through her fingers
a second time.
Have you practised this?
I've done it
in varying degrees of success,
so one extremely good,
but one less good,
with a small amount of sinkage.
There's no real going back at
this point, I've just gotta hope.
SANDI: The taller the Showstopper...
Something like that, hopefully.
Substantial.
..the more robust
the sponge will need to be,
to hold the weight of
the bakers' supersized creations.
I'm putting things
like glycerine inside,
trying to do things
to make it a very moist cake,
but it's still solid,
so it can stand up on itself.
It's a balance.
For her ambitious
three-tier design...
A lot of cake mix.
..Priya's not taking any chances.
It's quite a simple batter.
It just needs enough structure
for me to be able to carve
bits of it off, without it all
falling apart.
NOEL: Priya's sturdy chocolate and
orange sponge
will be shaped and decorated to look
like a child's pop-up storybook.
I've always loved books.
When I was younger, I used to
write my own little stories.
The Easter Bunny Who Lost His Eggs,
and Sally Sue's Glasses.
I took the trouble to, er,
put "copyright" and an ISBN number.
What sort of ten-year-old does that?
There you go,
that was me as a child.
English Literature student Henry...
I've made quite a few birthday cakes
at uni.
I was in the year where
everyone's got their 21st,
so the kitchen's been carnage.
..is also drawing on
his lifelong love of books.
I've based it around
The Magic Faraway Tree.
It's a really freaky book, reading
it now. But I loved it as a child.
Are you doing any of the weird
characters? Weird-character-face.
There's Moonface...
I'm not doing Moonface.
Based my career on Moonface.
Henry's magic tree will stand
in its own three-tiered,
triple-chocolate magical wood.
I've tried to get the sort of
woodland berry flavours into it,
and it shouldn't be
too sweet either,
cos children's birthday cakes can
be sickly. Tone that down a bit.
Somewhere between a child's dream
and this judge's taste buds.
That was the plan.
NOEL: One baker indulging in
his childhood self is Jamie.
It's like a salted caramel sponge,
with salted caramel buttercream
and caramel sauce.
I guess it's my favourite flavour,
as I was younger.
My twin brother, Alex,
likes this as well.
It's kind of a cake for all of us.
Based on his family's beloved
Schnauzer dogs,
cartoonish canine fondant features
will be the icing
on Jamie's dream birthday cake.
I haven't gone really big,
it's just a single tier,
but I should have enough time
to get it all done
and not be rushing around,
like I was yesterday.
I don't know why,
my butter's like, really stiff.
I don't think
I added too much flour.
I don't know why
it would be like that.
Oh, my goodness.
I forgot to add the eggs!
Rosie, I forgot to add my eggs.
Oh, no. Can you add them now?
No, I have to start again.
It's not worth the risk, is it?
No wonder I was like, urgh,
it was like mixing concrete.
Wow, already messed up.
That's good, isn't it?
Bakers, you only have
three hours left.
I thought he was about to say
minutes, for some reason.
That first hour went like that.
This is like deja vu, isn't it?
Whilst Jamie has to start
his cake batter once again...
Are you warm? You are warm.
..everyone else is ready
to begin baking.
Straight in.
So I'm just going to do
two at a time.
But with multiple cakes
needed to construct their
spectacular creations...
Two down, two to go.
..most are having to bake
in batches.
And now I'm going to do
that all over again.
With so much cake to support,
Alice is baking some reinforcements.
I'm just making some
lemon butter biscuits,
which are going to form some walls
and a roof for my sweet shop.
Both my parents are dentists
so, as a kid, sweets weren't
really on the menu.
Alice will be decorating
lemon-and-raspberry-flavoured sponge
to look like a sweet shop
with its own iced biscuit canopy.
I have to be quite careful
it's strong enough
that the roof doesn't collapse.
A bit of a sag in one
of my practices so
need to make they are
structurally sound.
To avoid total collapse without
scaling back on the size
of their Showstoppers...
It is literally just marshmallows
and Rice Krispies.
..Amelia, David and Phil
are all using
a lightweight cake alternative.
Because it's easy to mould and
I haven't got to make another cake,
so I'm just shaping the nose cone
for the rocket.
Hoping to blast himself
back up the scoreboard,
Phil's towering rocket-shaped
and sherbet-flavoured
sponge cake will be a nostalgic nod
to the 1969 moon landings.
There's a great story
of when the Russians
first sent a satellite into space.
It was called Sputnik.
The first one the Americans sent in,
it crashed immediately,
and they called it Kaputnik,
which I quite like.
Amelia is trying to figure out
how to avoid a Kaputnik of her own.
I am doing a carousel cake, and
there might be a tube in the middle
of the carousel, depending on time
and my nerves and everything else.
Inside Amelia's carousel will be red
velvet sponge and she's hoping
to have pink candy horses, merrily
going around her precarious pole.
The, like, logistics of sticking it,
balancing my cone on top,
yeah, it's just stressful.
David's Showstopper...
It's gonna be scary.
..is just as intimidating.
It's gonna be a snake, basically.
Snake? Yeah.
When I was a kid
I had an albino Burmese python.
I had a garter snake.
I had a slow worm.
Some of us have got snakes,
some of us have got worms, Paul.
Fiercely protecting an egg
full of baby jelly snakes,
David's terrifying chocolate
and orange snake cake
will be complete with a tongue,
fangs, and snakeskin.
I'm going with netting from a packet
of oranges and then spraying it.
I saw it on a make-up programme.
Someone was doing a snake.
It looks a bit like when they shed
their skin, doesn't it?
Yeah, so I might just put that
at the side afterwards then.
Good luck.
Brilliant, thank you very much.
Bakers, you are halfway through,
halfway through.
Argh.
Two hours left!
Let's hurry now a bit.
I've done about 20 minutes' work.
I had kind of safety net, which has
all been used up, probably.
But looking better than before.
They're coming out now.
Must not drop the cake.
While the first batch of cakes
are coming out of the oven...
And so far, so good.
..there's still plenty more
to be baked.
Got my biggest cakes
out of the oven.
My little ones are in the oven.
And if keeping track
of multiple baking...
Chill out.
..and cooling times
isn't hard enough...
What was that timer for?
..they've still got to find time to
make dozens of decorative
elements...
This is probably
going to make a mess.
..to turn their childhood
dreams into reality.
I am making a jungle cake.
This is going to be my tree,
which I am relying on for,
like, the whole cake, really.
Clinging on to Rosie's chocolate
tree will be a fondant monkey
and our second coiled snake.
A familiar sight for our baking vet.
Someone once brought in
a giant snake in my last job,
and it wrapped itself around
my boss's computer. Oh, wow.
Yeah, I was literally going, uh,
do I have to replace the computer
if the snake squishes it? Uh...
How, how do you persuade a snake to
let go of a computer?
Just sort of waited
and sort of pulled its tail a bit
and, you know, gently, and hoped.
Wow. It let go. It was fine.
These are gold bars
made of cinder toffee,
because when I was wee, I had
a pirate party and my mum made
this amazing treasure chest cake.
So, I'm going to give it a go
myself.
Michael's treasure chest will be
heaving with cinder toffee gold
and precious gems
made out of molten sugar.
Right, here we go.
It sort of needs to
fill to the very top,
cos otherwise you don't get
the full gem effect.
Ooh, nearly.
Ruined.
Right, I need to just move on.
Not only does Michael's
treasure need to set,
it's also at risk of
being plundered by Dan.
I'm baking a pirate island cake.
I've just heard what
Michael was doing.
I didn't copy it.
Dan's pirate island will be
formed from five tiers
of lime and coconut sponge.
And after a disastrous first day,
he's hoping he won't
have to walk the plank.
You've pulled it out, haven't you?
For this one. I'm trying.
You don't want to go
home first, do you?
No, I definitely don't.
If you go home first,
I will pull the tent down.
We'll do it together. That's it.
We'll graffiti Paul's car.
Let's do that.
We'll hide Prue's glasses.
So, Prue, dream birthday cake
Showstopper.
I mean, I think it's a great
challenge, because I think it
allows the bakers to really
bring their personality out.
The only big issue I think
they're all going to have
is finishing it off, cos the last
thing we want is just the sponge
with no decorative element to it.
It's the decoration that
will let them down.
I haven't actually finished
the whole thing decorated at home.
I've always been about
20 minutes over.
Pressure's on now to make sure I do.
Bakers, you have one hour remaining,
one hour!
Argh.
Just enough time for me
to do my fringe.
One hour is a bit tight.
Starting to feel the pressure.
It's good, came out clean. So, let
it cool before I put the fondant on.
So are you happy?
At the moment, yeah.
I'm, like, maybe a bit behind now
but I hope it works.
If you want me to push anyone's cake
on the floor, just let me know.
Dan's looking too comfortable.
Dan, all right, I'll push it
on the floor. See you in a bit.
I think I need to start assembling.
Everyone else is starting to begin.
Only when all of their
cakes are cooled...
Been in the fridge for 45 minutes,
so they're nice and cold now.
..can construction begin...
Not too much of a problem.
Just do that.
Once it gets iced
that should be all right.
..and the strength of their sponges
will be put to the test.
There you go, you would never know.
I dropped my cake. You OK?
No.
Oh, my God.
I think it's OK.
Oh, I think
I've got a stress hernia.
If the bakers don't carve...
This is the book, so it'll be,
like, sloped on the edges.
..stack...
I'm slicing the top
so that the cake is level.
..and shape with precision...
I just don't want it to go too deep
that it's going to collapse my cake.
..their entire Showstopper
structures could collapse.
Vanilla buttercream
going between the layers.
Let's just hope
they glue it together.
So I'm putting the passion fruit
curd on to sandwich.
I hope the passion fruit's going to
pack a punch but we'll see.
I'm just doweling the cake,
which means, when I come to
stack it, it won't collapse.
Have to quite careful with this.
It's just a bit wobbly.
If that doesn't stay up then
the whole thing will fall down.
So, going to shove these in there.
Can't do it.
Sorry.
I'm covering this in white fondant,
just going to airbrush
the colours onto it.
Cos I'm doing quite a simple cake,
I think it needs to look
almost perfect.
Oh, no. Calm down, calm down,
calm down, calm down.
This is the nose cone.
Just trying to use my hands.
This is a tiny little thing so I've
got to be careful with it, really.
Bakers, you have half an hour,
just half an hour.
I can do it in half an hour,
I can, I can.
Just add the final layer
and then it's decoration.
How much I do depends on
how much time I have.
This is the last mountain,
but I am worried now about time.
I didn't realise we had
as little left.
Getting there.
My tree is rubbish.
It's the worst tree I've ever made.
But I'm going to have to do my best
to try and fix it.
I'll put the biscuits in.
So you're going to split
the dog's head open
and confetti's going to come out.
You know that Rosie's a vet, right?
You've got to stitch it back up
again.
I really don't have time to fix it.
This is my isomalt waterfall,
which might not have worked out.
Start again.
It's... upright.
It's whether it can hold.
Stay.
Hasn't fallen over yet.
Looks a bit unstable to me.
Might have to deconstruct it
until I'm ready.
It's all right.
No pressure.
Bakers, you have ten minutes left.
Just throw food colouring at it.
It will be fine.
That's what I'm doing.
Michelle, do you think you're
on time? No. Close?
Um... no.
Panicked a bit now. Mine doesn't
really look like a birthday cake
now, does it?
Oh, God, I don't know
if I'm going to have time to put
the tube in the middle. So this is
now going to sit on there.
Yesterday the chicks
didn't have eyes,
but dogs definitely
have to have eyes.
Hey, you did a waterfall.
Ish.
Hopefully it'll stay.
Bakers, one minute remaining.
Urgh.
That was a happy sound.
Urgh. Urgh.
Oh, my days.
Don't worry, it's only our
childhood dreams on the line.
I'm not sure I can do
anything else, can I?
Oh, don't run out of icing now.
Come on.
I need to just pipe the face.
I'm out of time. So annoying.
Don't think they're going to stand.
I done it.
Done it. Right, beautiful bakers.
Your time is up.
All your first bakes are over.
You did it. Oh, my God.
That is not what I want to see
when I turn round.
Woof-woof!
Dan, that looks sick.
Don't. I feel sick.
It's judgment time for our bakers'
dream childhood birthday cakes.
Michelle, would you bring
up your birthday cake, please?
Wow, it's absolutely exquisite.
I like the detail and it's neat.
It's tidy.
Well, now it's just
gotta taste good.
It is a carrot cake with orange
cream cheese frosting.
It's a great looking carrot cake.
I'm dribbling.
Prue, you've gotta stop saying that.
I mean, I'm absolutely salivating.
I think it's wonderful.
Oh, thank you.
The balance of spices that you've
put in is perfect.
It's nice and moist inside there,
and the design as well.
It's faultless, actually.
Faultless. Faultless.
Thank you, thanks very much.
Well done.
Faultless.
SHE SIGHS
It's very delicate.
It's very charming.
Let's see what it tastes
like, shall we?
Wafts of chocolate,
it's just terrific.
It is a fantastic sponge.
The depth of flavour is beautiful.
You've got coffee in there,
which actually blends
beautifully with the chocolate.
I think you've done a good job
with your fairy garden.
Thanks.
Don't start.
That doesn't look like a book. Yeah.
This is just a little bit clumsy
but I love the concept.
I've made a chocolate orange sponge
and chocolate orange buttercream.
If I hadn't just had a better one,
I would've said it was an excellent
cake, but this is slightly drier.
If you'd spent less time with the
cake in the oven, and more time
getting it finished, you probably
would've been all right.
It's really impressive
and it didn't collapse.
It didn't collapse, no.
Some of it's a bit rough and ready,
but let's see what it tastes like.
Very light sponge.
That is a beautiful cake. Thank you.
When you do hit the raspberry, it is
deliciously balanced.
It's a bit simplistic,
but I think you've done well.
It's so effective.
Makes me feel quite nostalgic.
I can remember 1969
even if you boys can't.
First man on the moon, 1969.
Exactly. And I watched him land.
It is a good design,
however, it is leaning.
This is sherbet, isn't it?
Mm-hm. For me,
it's a little too sweet.
It needs more sharpness
to balance out the sweetness.
I would never have
thought of that for a cake.
The design is spectacular.
I think you've done a good job.
It's a good thing you've got the
blackberries there,
because it's quite a sweet cake.
You want that rich chocolate.
If you never had that blackberry
in there, I wouldn't like it at all.
You've been very
restrained about the colours.
This is a classy grown up's
version of a child's dream.
Did you run out of time? Yeah.
I expected a little bit
more than that.
But let's see what it tastes like.
It's a red velvet cake with white
chocolate ganache and raspberry jam.
It's a pretty claggy cake.
It doesn't taste good, actually.
I see what you're going for, but I
think you're slightly off the mark.
I love the idea that you dropped it.
Yeah. Which happens always when
you've got children on the beach.
Always. Yeah.
That's a crumbly cake.
It's raspberry ripple and coconut.
It must be a bit over-baked cos
it's a little bit dry as a result.
Yeah, OK. Flavours are good.
Concentrate on your baking.
OK.
I think it looks absolutely amazing.
It's charming. I think it's a
fantastic looking cake.
The egg has something in it as well.
Oh, it's baby snakes.
Oh, wow.
Brilliant and creepy. In a good way.
That's a very nice thin
layer of icing, well done.
That is a beautiful cake.
You have the chocolate,
you have the citrus.
It all marries up lovely,
and to finish it off looking like
that, well done, David.
Very, very good cake.
I think it's a little bit
simplistic for me.
OK. A bit clumsy.
Well, I very seldom disagree with
Paul but I love the exterior.
Tell us all about
your birthday cake.
It's a red velvet cake with
an Italian meringue buttercream.
Nice equal layers.
The cake's baked beautifully.
The Italian buttercream is
silky smooth.
I think the interior, for me, works.
The exterior doesn't.
OK.
Oh, my goodness. Looks great.
I think you've ended
up with a design
that any kid would be
happy getting on their birthday.
Remind me of those flavours again.
It's a chocolate and coffee sponge
with salted caramel buttercream.
It's a great looking sponge.
I like the texture. But I think it
needed a bit more chocolate.
It's good, just
think about your flavours.
I like the gold bars.
Very good.
Like a couple of big kids.
Well done, Michael. Thank you.
Thank you.
It's a waterfall.
Very beautifully done.
It's clever. It's very clever.
I mean, I could see kids
going for that straight away.
It's lime and coconut cake
with coconut buttercream and
passion fruit curd.
Strong coconut.
Where's the passion fruit?
It's in the curd. It's there.
It's so slight.
There's more of it in the middle.
BAKERS LAUGH
It's not there either.
If you go further up, there's more.
Get it?
Not really, no.
Your flavour ideas were sound,
but you're not bringing it through.
But the design I think
is very, very good.
How many sponges are in there? Four.
And you got salted
caramel in between each layer?
Yeah, it's like a...
HIGH-PITCHED: ..car... Ooh, crikey.
How old are you? That's
embarrassing.
Is your voice breaking?
Finally.
Uh, yes.
So it's got buttercream and caramel
sauce between each layer.
Mine looks pretty good. Oh, I see.
They're your dog biscuits. Yeah.
Actually those biscuits are really
nice. Are they? Mmm. Nice.
One mouthful's lovely.
It's like eating a toffee.
Yeah. But a whole slice would be
overwhelmingly salted caramel.
Your cake's over-baked.
There's not a lot of finesse
about this cake.
Thank you very much. Thank you.
Well, that didn't go well, did it?
I guess you don't really know
until you're under pressure,
what it's going to be like.
Uh...
I don't know what to say.
Hold on, hold on.
Faultless.
Paul said he didn't like my cake
during cake week.
Staying in this competition now
would mean everything.
I need a lifeline. Throw me a bone.
I'm just prepared for the worst
and if it happens, it happens.
Oh, my God, I don't want to get
filmed with tears in my eyes.
So cringe, isn't it?
Prue and Paul must now decide
who will be our first Star Baker
and who will be leaving the tent.
That was amazing. I thought they
really came into their own.
Their personalities
started to come out.
When we walked into the room
it was just this sea of
amazing Show Stoppers.
My favourite is still the first one.
Michelle's cake. Michelle's.
She did OK in the Technical.
She did well in the Signature
but this has elevated her,
so she's up there or thereabouts.
I think Steph deserves a
mention up there as well.
Steph's cake was pretty good.
Third in Technical, she did pretty
well in the Signature too.
But Henry who had done brilliantly
in the Technical. Yeah.
Not so pleased?
Henry had a good day yesterday,
but today, he's not done so well.
No, he hasn't.
People, for me, who are in a little
bit of trouble, I have to say Jamie.
His Signature was good
but he was bottom of Technical.
Today he struggled with the
Show Stopper.
Dan, because I was trying to
hunt down the flavour,
although the design was pretty good.
You've had 13 pieces of cake,
are you all right?
No. Not quite.
Well done, bakers.
That is your first week in the tent
successfully completed.
Sigh of relief, I'm sure.
And I have to tell you, Paul
and Prue say the standard
has been incredibly high,
so well done.
I've got the fantastic
job of announcing Star Baker.
The person who is Star
Baker this week is...
Michelle.
Yes. Oh!
Woo!
Amazing. Thank you.
So that leaves me with the horrible
job of sending somebody home,
and I have to say, even
after the first week,
it is incredibly difficult.
But I'm afraid one of you has to
depart and that person is...
..Dan. I'm so sorry.
Hey, don't worry.
I know, mate. I know, mate.
I had a bad week.
Definitely I'll take away
the friendships.
What are we going to do without you?
Can't imagine how everyone's bonded.
It's so strange.
Oh, Dan! Aw!
He's such a beautiful man. Aw!
I'm not going to miss the
baking under pressure,
just going to miss
everybody in that tent.
Sorry, mate.
No, no, it's all right. Sorry.
He's a great baker, Dan,
but unfortunately,
it all boiled down to
his Signature Bake,
and it was that that was the
cause of him going.
Pick it up a bit, all right. Yeah,
yeah. It was really close.
I thought it was going to be me.
I'm looking forward to coming back
and almost starting again.
Convince people I can bake.
Yeah, but, when you come on and
you can't even bake a cake properly
doesn't look good, does it?
Oh, my God. You must be so pleased.
I can't get over it. I'm so shocked.
I never, ever thought
I'd actually get on the Bake Off.
So, to get Star Baker,
I'm just so proud.
I don't know what to say.
I'm just happy.
Well done, Michelle.
Thank you so much.
I want the recipe, please.
Oh, thank you.
You know, this is the tenth
anniversary of Bake Off
and what a way to start.
That Show Stopper was pretty well
the best cake I've ever eaten.
I've got something to tell you.
Yeah?
I'm still in. Yes!
And, uh, Prue Leith wants my carrot
cake recipe. Michelle!
Uh, and I'm Star Baker.
Oh, my God!
I couldn't be prouder. Do you know
what, I knew you could do it.
I've had a cry as well.
Yeah, I'm close to that as well.
Group hug, group hug, group hug, get
'em in. Get 'em in.
Aw!
Next time...
Ooh. ..we're baking biscuits.
Praying.
..with a Signature Bake completely
covered in chocolate...
Oh!
..a classic old school Technical...
Doesn't look very appealing,
does it?
..and the most intricately detailed
giant biscuit sculptures
the Bake Off has ever seen.
I'm making an organ.
But who will be our second
Star Baker...
No pressure at all.
..and whose Bake Off...
Oh, it's off.
..is about to crumble?
It's getting stickier and stickier.
I still kind if can't feel
that I can do it.
No!
Subtitles by Red Bee Media